even for Mission Control space is full
of surprises NASA's spacecraft has been
sending back photos as it barreled
towards a tiny rock in the outer reaches
of the solar system but scientists
hadn't expected the close-up here's
where we were just just a couple days
ago on December 31st 2018
well that image is so 2018 meet Ultima
Thule it's a snowman if it's anything at
all ultimate to lays improbable shape is
formed from two smaller rocks that have
been drawn together by their tiny
gravity as they orbit the Sun four
billion miles away with a temperature
around minus 240 degrees the rock is
almost frozen in time giving scientists
a glimpse of what the solar system was
like 4.6 billion years ago these are
what's the only remaining basic building
blocks and the backyard of the solar
system we can see that everything else
that we live on or see through our
telescopes or visit with our spacecraft
were formed from so I think we should
think of New Horizons as a time machine
like the wayback machines we set 2.2
times zero and that has brought us back
to the very beginning of solar system
history to a place where we can observe
the most primordial building blocks of
the planets the New Horizons spacecraft
took hundreds of images as it's skimmed
past the rock at 32,000 miles an hour
they'll be sent back over the next 20
months helping scientists understand an
extraordinary distant world Thomas More
Sky News